[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHET HAASE: Hey.
[CLAPPING]
DAN SANDLER: Hey everybody.
Welcome back to
What's New in Android.
I'm Dan Sandler from
the System UI team.
CHET HAASE: I'm Chet Haase
from the Android Toolkit team.
ROMAIN GUY: And I'm
Romain Guy from--
I still don't have
a name for my team.
So from the Android team.
[LAUGHTER]
And you may remember
us from other talks,
such as What's New
in Android 2017,
What's New in Android 2016,
What's New in Android 2015,
What's New in Android 2014.
Not What's New in Android 2013.
CHET HAASE: We don't
talk about that one.
ROMAIN GUY: We don't
DAN SANDLER: You know,
that was the time
that we had Jelly Bean
two years in a row.
It was brilliant.
We didn't have to redo
the logo or anything.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAIN GUY: But now--
CHET HAASE: What's
New in Android,
what I like to call
the Android keynote.
Nobody else does.
But I like to call it that.
Because this is where we talk to
you about all of the developer
stuff going on in
the Android platform.
In particular, let's talk
about Android P. Specifically,
let's talk today about--
oh, hang on.
Android APIs.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAIN GUY: All right, first
we'll start with distribution.
You saw in the keynote we
introduced the dynamic ad
bundles.
[? Tor's ?] demo
was pretty clear.
It's pretty easy for you.
All you have to do is
click your different menu
when you build your application.
And we're going to
save you some space.
It's going to be faster
and easier for your users
to download your app.
And I'm sure you have a
lot of questions about it.
So we have a couple of
talks this afternoon,
at 5:00 PM and 6:00 PM.
Go there if you want answers,
because we don't have them.
CHET HAASE: So you're going
to see a slide a whole lot
like this through
the rest of the talk.
I feel like the main
function we serve
in this talk is to tell you
the other talks to go to.
We're like the appendix.
We're like the index for
the rest of the content.
DAN SANDLER: I mean, we're
like obsolete, like vestigial.
Is that what it is?
CHET HAASE: I don't like
to think about that.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah.
Let's be clear.
A lot of people back at work
have done all the hard work.
We just get to go on stage and
talk about their hard work.
CHET HAASE: So speaking
of that, let's talk
about Android Jetpack.
We heard Steph talk about
this in the developer keynote.
This is a set of
components, as well as
guidance on how to build
better Android applications.
All of you are familiar
with most of what
is in Android Jetpack already.
What we're doing is
adding to it over time
with stuff that's going
to make it even better.
And we're also
improving it over time.
One of the major steps
that we're taking
is what I like to think of
as a refactor, because it's
a refactor.
My favorite thing about
the support library
is how the package names embed
the release number in them.
So, for example, we
support things like v4.
Actually we don't
support v4 anymore.
We have a min SDK
of at least 14 now.
But it's in the package name.
Isn't that a little bit silly?
So we're doing away with that.
We're doing a whole lot
of tedious renaming.
And we're also providing
tools to make it easier
for you to do the similar
refactoring that you're
going to need to do
in your application,
as well as in Android Studio.
Everything is being renamed
to something more appropriate
called Androidx.
If you want to know more
about the details of that,
the renaming, as well as doing
more modular, more fine-grained
splits to make sure that you
don't drag in too much stuff,
go to the talk.
Learn what's new in
Android Support Library.
Also, there was an
article that was
posted on the Android Developers
blog about a half hour ago.
Check that out for more
of the details there.
Let's talk about
Android Test, which
is part of this new
Jetpack thing going on.
Android Test is the
ATSL stuff, the Espresso
stuff that hopefully you were
already using really good ways
to test your application.
Now, they provide first class
Kotlin support, as well as
more elegant APIs for reducing
a lot of the boilerplate.
Here's a simple example.
We used to have a
way of asserting,
which, A, was not
necessarily obvious
in the parameters
you were passing.
Also, unobvious in the
order of the parameters
that you were passing.
And then it would give you
an error message that also
didn't really help very much.
So we have something a
little more sensible now.
You can assert that
it's actually working
on the visible property.
And the error message
gives you something more
that you can work with
a little bit better.
Go to the Frictionless
Android Testing
talk for more information
about that stuff.
Jetpack architecture is about
the architecture components
that were announced
last year at I/O
and then iterated with
feedback from the community,
and finally went
1.0 in the fall.
So we have the release
parts of those,
which includes all the Lifecycle
stuff, and the ViewModel stuff,
as well as the Room, the
persistent data model
stuff, and LiveData.
So hopefully you are
using that stuff already,
at least in your
new applications.
And what we also
have is recently we
released the paging library for
doing asynchronous data paging
into RecyclerView.
That was alpha, then
beta, because that's
how those things work.
And now it's 1.0 this week.
So please start using that.
And we also talked in
the developer keynote
about a couple of new things
that you should check out soon.
WorkManager is
currently in preview.
There's going to
be a talk about it.
It's about job
scheduling, but job
scheduling in a way where
we handle all the cases back
in previous releases,
instead of you having
to use specific
approaches, depending
on what version and
device that you're on.
Also, navigation.
It turns out that up versus
back is a hard problem
for applications to solve.
We are making that much easier.
And we're integrating
with the tool
to make it even easier yet.
So go to all these talks.
There's an overview
talk, as well as
specific talks on Navigation
Controller and WorkManager,
and also a talk on
RecyclerView and Paging.
Me?
Again?
ROMAIN GUY: It says
your name on the slide.
CHET HAASE: I keep building
suspense into this thing.
What's going to happen next?
Who's he going to
hand the clicker to?
It's still mine.
DAN SANDLER: It's still you.
CHET HAASE: OK.
Let's talk about battery.
This is one of the
ongoing efforts in Android
to help the users,
because it turns out
battery is really important.
We're all power users.
Unfortunately, we just
keep using the power.
So what can we do about it?
We can create these
app standby buckets.
We're going to monitor
the usage of applications,
and see how actively
the user is using it,
and then make determinations
about how much access
that application has
to ongoing things
in the system which are going
to take up more battery.
We also had background
restrictions
that the user has the ability
to kick in in settings.
So if an application
is behaving badly,
let's say holding wake locks
for long periods of time,
or waking up constantly,
or accessing services
way more than they should
when it's not on a charger,
then we'll note that and
expose that in settings.
And then the user can
take some action on that
if they deem that necessary.
Go to the battery session
on Thursday morning
to learn more of
the details there.
ROMAIN GUY: So one of the things
that we've been focusing on
with Android P is privacy.
Maybe that's what it stands for.
So one of the
things we've done is
that when your app
is in the background,
it doesn't have access to
the microphone anymore.
It doesn't have access
to the camera anymore.
And it doesn't have access
to the sensor kind of.
So you won't receive the data
from the sensors automatically.
You can manually pull
from the sensors,
and you'll get batch
updates, but the best thing
to do if you want to get
access to the sensor data
is to keep a foreground
service running instead.
So no more microphone.
No more camera for you.
I think I've heard in the past
that some apps were trying
to stay alive in memory
by playing a white noise
or keeping the microphone on.
Don't do that anymore.
It's not OK.
Kotlin-- it's this little
thing we announced last year.
So we are busy.
We want to make it better
for all the Kotlin developers
out there.
I'm sure there's a
lot of you here today.
So some of the things
we've been doing,
the R team has been really busy
with D8, R8, and ART itself.
They've been looking at the byte
code generated by the Kotlin
compiler.
They've analyzed some of
the byte code patterns that
were different from the
ones generated by the Java
programming language compiler.
And they've been optimizing
for those patterns.
We've also been adding a lot
of nullability annotations
to our Java APIs, both
in the core libraries,
so libcore, and our
support libraries
to make it easier for you to use
the platform APIs when you're
in Kotlin.
And finally, we
launched on GitHub
a new library
called Android KTX.
It's a set of Kotlin extensions
for existing platform APIs.
And the goal here is to
try to take advantage
of some of the Kotlin
language features
to make existing
APIs easier to use.
They're already easier to
use just by using Kotlin,
but with the extension
they get even better.
And I want to thank
the community,
because we've received
dozens of pull requests,
and also bugs and feature
requests from you.
And we've accepted
a bunch of them.
So if you have
ideas, if you have
things that you would like
to see in Android KTX,
please go to GitHub, and
we'll take a look at your PR.
And this is an example
of the kind of code
you can write with KTX.
If you want to
create a bitmap, you
don't have to specify
its ARGB 8.8.8.8 anymore.
You can call applyCanvas,
which automatically
creates the canvas for you.
It becomes this.
And at the bottom you can see,
for instance, the destructuring
assignment for color integer.
So you don't have to do
any shifting or masking
of the int into bytes.
We'll take care of that for you.
There is a talk by Jack Wharton
on Thursday at 10:30 AM.
He's going to go through
most of the extensions.
He's going to talk
about the philosophy
behind the extensions,
how we write them, what
are the kind of extensions that
we want to see in that library
that we're not looking
for in that library.
So before you do all
the work and send a PR,
go attend that
talk to understand
what we're looking for.
CHET HAASE: We already
talked about the Android Test
stuff that is part
of Jetpack earlier.
That's probably a
better, more holistic way
to test your application.
But if there is a
specific situation
in which you find it
necessary or helpful
to mock the framework--
and I don't mean ridicule it,
because that wouldn't be nice--
then it is possible to do that
in easier ways now in Mockito.
We are not changing
the framework,
but we're actually integrating
changes into Mockito itself.
So you can now
mock final methods.
And soon you should be able
to mock static methods.
[CLAPPING]
[CHEERING]
ROMAIN GUY: And Chet
is making that face
because he doesn't
understand why
that is so interesting to you.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: And system
created objects like activity,
eventually.
Working on that internally,
but it should be on the way
eventually.
A background text measurement.
This is part of a bunch
of smaller changes
that we made in the text area.
It turns out that measurement
is really expensive.
So most applications do text.
And I would bet that the text
operations in your application
are some of the most expensive
going on in the UI thread,
which can contribute to jank.
Wouldn't it be nicer if
you could offload that
to a background thread so
that by the time you actually
need to render the
text, or perform
those operations on the UI
thread, most of the hard work
was done for you?
So the observation
is that 80% to 90%
of the operations that
are necessary for actually
displaying text happen
in text measurement.
Well, we've made it possible and
much easier to actually perform
this as a background operation.
So we have a class
called pre-computed text.
And you can query that.
And you can say, I want
you to pre-measure this.
And then you can set that text
that's spannable on the text
view later whenever you want.
So you do it in background
threads, like this.
You say create this thing.
And then you can set
that on the text view
later when you actually need it.
Should be much faster.
Magnifier is something
that if you're
using the preview
releases you might see,
if you select some text, it pops
up this little bar up above it.
It makes it easier to
manipulate the cursor.
That's really great for text,
but the other cool thing
about it is that it's also
available for your applications
for any other use case.
So there's an API
that allows you
to pop up this
magnifier for whatever
happens to be in your view.
So you can show this, and
dismiss it, and use it
for your stuff as well.
So core functionality that
we want in the system user
interface.
But also useful
APIs for developers
to use for their own purposes.
I don't know if you've worked
with your design department,
and they've specified something
about text in your UI,
and, OK, well, I want this
aligned this many dips away
from the top.
And I want the
baseline on the bottom
this many dips away
from the bottom.
And then you have this
interspersed vertical alignment
stuff going on.
And then you sort of puzzle
with this for a while.
And you basically
futz with padding
in all kinds of
different configurations
to sort of get it to where
they wanted to get it.
We have worked with
that and created
some new attributes, and
methods, and properties for you
to use that make
that much easier.
So we allow you to just
pass us the information
about the baseline
alignment calculations
that you would like to perform.
And then we'll futz with
padding on your behalf.
Smart Linkify.
I think of this as being
Linkify, but smarter.
So we already have
the ability to ask
for links in a block of
text, and it'll detect things
like phone numbers
and addresses.
But we also have the ability,
through machine learning
models, and stuff that you've
seen through smart text
selection, to detect
other entities.
We can do the same
thing with Linkify.
It takes a little bit
potentially longer.
So you do this off thread.
So you would basically
generate the links off thread,
and then set it
on your text view
later, using code
similar to this.
There's a text talk
on Wednesday evening.
So please go to that for
more details about all
of this, as well as more.
ROMAIN GUY: So location.
Now you can take advantage
of a new package,
android.net.wifi.rtt.
It's the WiFi round
trip time API.
It requires compatible
hardware on your phone.
It also requires a
compatible access point.
And it allows you to find
a precise location indoors
for the user's device.
You need to request the
Find Location permission.
And you don't need to
connect to the access point.
So if you're building
an application that
requires locating the user
inside a big building,
you can take advantage
of this API in Android P.
CHET HAASE: Accessibility
has some improvements
for navigation through the app.
So it's easier
for you to declare
these functional blocks.
It makes it easier
for accessible users
to understand how things are
being grouped on the screen.
There's an important talk
on accessibility right now?
No, that's tomorrow.
OK.
Hopefully it's tomorrow.
I'm not sure that's correct.
ROMAIN GUY: It's tomorrow
or 40 minutes ago.
CHET HAASE: OK.
All right.
DAN SANDLER: It's on YouTube.
CHET HAASE: Yes, it is.
Eventually.
Like now.
Yeah.
I think I got the day wrong.
Sorry about that.
It's now.
If you're in the
wrong talk, I invite
you to go to the other one.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAIN GUY: Oh, my turn.
Security.
New API in Android P, the
Unified BiometricDialog.
So we deprecated the
FingerprintManager
because there are more ways
to authenticate yourself
with your body than
just with a fingerprint.
Could be your eyes.
Could be whatever else that
device manufacturers will
think of next.
So now we have a single
UI for all devices
and all means of authentication.
We also have stronger
protections for private keys.
And very important
in your application,
if you're using the
API, Build.SERIAL,
it doesn't work anymore.
The API is still there.
But it basically
returns bogus data.
So you cannot rely
on it at all anymore.
CHET HAASE: Various
changes in Enterprise.
Just a couple of them
that are interesting.
We made it easier to
work with work profile
apps or different profile apps
by having these different tabs
that you can associate with
them so they're not all mixed
together, but you can actually
have these whole sections
of these different profiles.
Also, you're allowed to lock
packages to a specific task.
You could have a launcher with
just a minimum set of a group
or a single application.
That works in combination
with the ability
to have ephemeral users, which
now gives you kiosk mode.
So you will no longer
have experiences
like I had on a
recent flight, as you
can see from my blurry
picture, where you see a movie
and you wonder what operating
system is running under that.
So you swipe from the
bottom of the screen.
You see the ICS navigation bar.
And then you press
on the recent tasks,
and you swipe the movie
away, and you confuse
the heck out of the system.
ROMAIN GUY: I have
to admit, that's what
I try every time I'm
on a plane these days.
And it works a surprising
number of times.
DAN SANDLER: Homework
for all of you.
CHET HAASE: This is like
fun for Android engineers.
This is what we do.
ROMAIN GUY:
Hopefully this is not
linked to the plane navigation.
DAN SANDLER: Now?
Is it OK?
Can I talk now?
Is that all right?
CHET HAASE: Very briefly.
DAN SANDLER: Very briefly.
All right.
Let's talk about actually a
lot of the system UI stuff
typically gets shown at
one of the keynotes that
precedes What's New in Android.
So you've all seen a
lot of the great stuff
that users are getting.
I'm going to talk to you
about some of the stuff
that as developers you
might be interested in.
The first one is display
cutouts, a.k.a.--
well, there are
other names for it.
These are coming to the
ecosystem all over the place.
And so as a developer, you need
to know where it's safe to draw
and where it isn't.
When you get your window insets
on viewWindowInset, something
or other, you get
DisplayCutout object,
which gives you all
kinds of interesting data
about the cutout.
But you're probably
going to want
to use something called
windowLayoutInDisplayCutoutMode
on your window.
So there's the basic
way, which is, I never
want to overlap the cutout.
Just leave a black bar
at the top or the bottom.
Whatever.
I'm not all that interested.
A little more advanced
would be display
cutout mode default, which
is, if you were already
going to clear the
status bar just fine,
we'll let the app window draw
underneath the cutout as well.
So you'll get the
nice action bar
color extending
through the status bar
and extending
underneath the cutout.
Better still, or
more advanced still
is shortEdges cutout
mode, which means
essentially any time there's
a cutout on the short edges
of the device, and
we're in portrait,
I will just draw underneath.
You don't have to
do anything special.
And in that
situation you do need
to look at the display cutout
and ask it for the safe insets.
Essentially, well, OK,
I'm drawing everywhere.
But you tell me what single
rectangle of the screen
is safest to draw in.
And then finally, the
cosmic version of this.
You can do shortEdges,
but you can actually
get the bounds of the
cutout as a region.
So you will get the
exact set of rectangles
that are unavailable
to you on the screen
so you can display
UI in the corners
if the corners are available.
Or if there's a
corner cutout, you
can move things
out of the way so
that it's visible in the
center of the display.
This is the most
advanced version of it.
And you can put the
electrical tape away,
because you can actually
simulate notches now
in developer options
on your device.
This is really, really exciting.
Slices actually was what we
were calling it internally.
And we liked it so
much we just kept it.
You've seen Slices now
in a couple of keynotes.
It's essentially something that
we've discovered and learned
about on system UI and in
the toolkit over many years
of dealing with remote views
for app widgets dealing
with notifications.
Essentially the problem of
getting content from your app
into some other place.
So Slices is our new
approach to remote content
that you can actually use to
project UI into your own app,
or into other apps
that support it.
It's very structured.
This is not sort of, here's a
canvas, or an absolute layout.
Go nuts with it.
We give you a
structure to fill out,
and a whole bunch of very
flexible templates in which
to populate that data
with some display
hints so that the receiving end
of the slice, the slice host,
kind of knows what
to do with it.
These are interactive.
These are updateable.
This is meant to be
something that holds rich UI.
Sliders, controls, live
information, possibly
videos, things that
actually feel like real UI,
as opposed to a snapshot
of something happening
in a distant process somewhere.
Slices are addressable
by content URI.
And this is how they're
passed around the system,
and how they're passed
along to app indexing
to be shown in
context like search.
And then finally,
Slices is entirely
inside the support library.
It's entirely in Jetpack.
So it's backwards compatible.
You can use Slices all
the way back to API 19.
There's a great talk
about Slices tomorrow
bright and early, building
interactive results
for Google Search.
Come to find out more about
how all this technology works
and how you can build your own.
Related to Slices is Actions.
You can think of these as
shortcuts with parameters.
Romain likes to think of
them as visible intent.
This is essentially a
deep link into your app
with some additional payload.
It's not just a link to music.
It's linked to the particular
album, or something like that.
And you saw these as
well in the keynotes,
showing up in a predictive
space inside our app launching
experience, actions you
define in an actions XML
file that goes into
your APK or app bundle.
And that too can get
registered with app indexing
so that search results
and predictive features
can show those actions.
And there's a talk
about this too,
Thursday, slightly less
early in the morning.
Integrating your Android apps
with the Google Assistant.
Notifications.
There was a lot of great
stuff about digital wellness
and controlling notifications
that you saw in the keynote.
And I'm very excited about it in
P. I'm going to talk about some
of the developer stuff,
though, that we have in here.
We asked users
what notifications
are most important to them.
Users love messages.
So we focused our energy in
enhancing the messaging style
API.
You can do inline images now.
You can do participant images,
and attach other metadata
about the participant.
And we finally now have
UI for smart reply,
which we've had on
Android Wear for years.
So when you use
RemoteInput.setChoices,
those will now appear as chips
right in the notification
so you can respond instantly
in the middle of a chat
without leaving the
notification shade.
And there's tons of
other stuff as usual.
I had one other
slide that we added
about 10 minutes ago to this
deck about notifications.
And I'm just going
to let that sit
on the screen for
a little while.
[CLAPPING]
So if you're doing
something in the background,
the user still needs to know.
But Android P does a much better
job of allowing notifications
that you may
already have running
testify to that
background activity,
including things like
overlaying windows.
So with that, talk about
the runtime, Romain.
ROMAIN GUY: So probably one
of the most important things
for you as an Android
developer is to understand
our deprecation policy.
It was announced
a few weeks ago.
Soon we will require all
the applications to target
some of the newest API levels.
And we're doing
that to make sure
that we can keep the
security level of Android
as high as possible,
as well as performance,
and a lot of other nice things.
So what does it mean for you?
As of August this
year, new applications
published on the Play Store will
have to target API level 26.
And as of November
this year, any update
to an existing application that
you publish on the Play Store
will have to target API 26.
And you can expect those
numbers to go up over time.
If you have native code
in your application,
we've been supporting 32-bit
and 64-bit for a few years now.
We will make 64-bit
APIs required
as of August of next year.
You'll still be able
to ship 32-bit support
in your application, but we will
ask you to ship 64-bit as well.
One of the reasons to ship
64-bit on 64-bit devices
is that you get better
performance and much
better code out of it.
If you want to know more
about the deprecation policy,
there is a talk on
Thursday afternoon.
And I'm sure you'll have a
lot of questions for the folks
there.
App compatibility.
If you've tried the
developer preview in P,
you might have noticed
something different
if you're one of those
naughty applications that
uses some of our private APIs.
On Android we have two types
of private APIs, the APIs that
are actually marked private.
And then there's this
weird @hide thing
that we use in our source code.
It's a Java Doc tag that
we process especially
to indicate that this
is a public API for us.
Not for you.
Just for us.
And we're a bit jealous because
a lot of you are using them.
So from now on, a
lot of those APIs
will trigger warnings
in one form or another.
It might be toast,
or it might be logs
when you make an illegal call.
For some of these APIs
we need to hear from you
that you need those APIs
for your application
to keep working.
Sometimes it's
just an oversight.
We didn't make the API public.
It's just because we
didn't think about it.
So please go to
this URL, and let
us know if there's
an API that you
think should be made public.
We might say yes.
We might also say no.
We have three types of lists.
I won't go into too
much detail here.
But basically, if an API
falls into the blacklist,
you will not be able
to call it ever.
I'm not sure if we have anything
in the blacklist right now.
But those will evolve over time.
So, again, let us know
what APIs you need.
CHET HAASE: This is one
of the important reasons.
This is why we ship previews.
We need you to go out there
and try your applications
on the previews,
because this is the time
to find out when there's
problems that either you
can fix before the real
release is out there,
or you can let us know
if it's a problem that we
need to work on instead.
ROMAIN GUY: And
that's Chet trying
to increase his engagement
with his podcast.
So there's this podcast
called ADB, Android Developer
Backstage.
And in episode
89, they had-- who
did you have in the episode?
CHET HAASE: Brian Carlstrom.
ROMAIN GUY: Brian Carlstrom.
And they talked about this
app compatibility issue,
and what it means for you.
So go listen to it.
NDK.
The release 17 of
the NDK brings a lot
of very interesting things.
So, first of all,
the neural networks
APIs that were part
of API level 27.
We also have a new shared memory
API if you do a lot of JNI.
More importantly, we
have finally ASAN,
the address sanitizer to
make sure your code doesn't
scribble all over the memory.
Now you don't need a rooted
device anymore to use it.
And we also have an
undefined behavior sanitizer.
It can be very difficult to
detect undefined behaviors
in your C or C++ code.
So now there's a tool for that.
We finally removed support
for the deprecated APIs.
So if you still use ARMv5 or
MIPS, MIPS 32-bit or 64-bit,
support is gone.
You should not be
shipping those anymore.
In the upcoming release,
release 18, we will remove GCC.
So the GCC compiler was
deprecated last year.
Now everything is compiled
with Clang in the NDK.
We think we gave enough time.
So GCC is going away.
So if you're still
using it, maybe you
should not be in this talk.
You should go fix your code.
[LAUGHTER]
And finally, we added support
for the simpleperf CPU
profiler.
And we also have support
in Android Studio
for native profiling.
So you don't even have to
type anything in the terminal.
Graphics and media.
The camera APIs are
getting better and better.
We've added a lot of things
that we were using ourselves
in the camera applications.
For instance, we give you
access to the timestamps
of the optical
image stabilization.
So if you want to build
the kind of stabilization
we've built in the video
recording part of the camera
application, now you can.
If your app is doing
a lot of selfies
and using the
display as a flash,
you can tell the
camera that you're
doing that so you can adapt
the exposure accordingly.
We have support for USB cameras.
I haven't seen any use for
it, but I've heard some of you
ask about it.
So now it's available.
Multi-camera support.
There are some phones
coming out out there
with multiple cameras in
the back, or in the front
I suppose.
And now we can expose them as
a logical camera that contains
more than one stream of data.
ImageDecoder.
I'm sure a lot of you are
familiar with BitmapFactory.
And if you're not fond
of that API, trust me,
we're not either.
So there's a new one
called ImageDecoder.
It's part of Android P. The idea
is to make it not only easier
to decode images, but also
to make it possible to decode
animated images.
So ImageDecoder can decode
bitmaps, but also drawables,
including animated drawables.
CHET HAASE: There's this new
thing called animated GIFs.
I don't know.
All the kids are using them.
It's possible to
actually load those now.
ROMAIN GUY: So there
are a few concepts
that you have to learn when
you learn ImageDecoder.
And we're going to go
through them in an example.
So we have the
concept of the source.
We have the concept
of the post processor,
and finally, the
header listener.
So this is what
the API looks like.
First, you have to
call createSource
on the ImageDecoder.
The source can be an asset.
It could be a file descriptor.
It can be many different things.
And the goal here is that
once you create a source,
you can decode multiple
images from the same source.
This is particularly useful if
you want to build thumbnails.
You can decode the same source
once at high resolution,
once at lower resolution, or
even intermediate resolutions.
And that can be done from
multiple worker threads.
Then you can call decodeBitmap.
You pass the source.
And you can optionally
pass a header listener.
So the header listener,
we have a lambda.
It gives you back
the decoder itself,
the metadata about the
image and the source.
And it's inside
the header listener
that you can set the options.
So in BitmapFactory you
had bitmapfactory.options
that you had to
pass through Decode.
Here you have to wait for the
header listener to be invoked.
CHET HAASE: We
should point out too,
that set target
size, that's kind
of a fundamental difference
where the old bitmap--
DAN SANDLER: It's
up there for them.
CHET HAASE: No.
I know.
I see that.
It's right there it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHET HAASE: That's
a huge difference.
Like before, if you wanted
the right target size,
you needed to work with, what?
In density?
As well as?
ROMAIN GUY: In sample
size, in density,
and do a lot of trickery.
CHET HAASE: We didn't know
how they worked either.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: So a lot easier now.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah.
Usually our answer
was, figure it out.
Anyways, so now you
can just tell us
what size you want
the bitmap to be in.
And we'll take care
of it, finally.
And you can also set
the post processor.
So the post processor
is something
with a simple interface.
It gives you a canvas so you
can draw on the bitmap right
after it's decoded so you can
add a header, like your title,
or some metadata on it.
Media.
We are adding support in
the platform for the HDR
profile of VP9 so you
can play HDR videos
in your applications.
YouTube was doing it, but
they had their own way
of decoding videos.
If you own a device that
doesn't support HDR,
the playback will be in
low dynamic range instead.
But on a device that's
capable, like a Pixel 2,
you will be able to see the
HDR stream in all its glory.
We're also adding
support, and bear with me,
cause it's a little
bit confusing,
a format called HEIF.
Yeah.
It rolls off the tongue.
The High Efficiency
Image Format.
So it's based on HEVC,
which was also called H.265.
And the filename extension
is commonly HEIC.
I don't know why they
used different letters.
But that's what they did.
So we have to deal with it.
So it is a container.
And it can store
multiple images.
So you can use it to store
a single image with higher
quality and higher compression
ratios than JPEG, for instance.
JPEG is a lot easier to say.
I like JPEG.
But you can also
sew multiple images
if you want animated
images or short movies.
This is part of the
support library,
or, I guess, Jetpack now.
And this is not part
of the compressed API
that you find on bitmap.
Because it's a container,
it works differently.
So this is what it looks like.
You have to create a builder.
You have to tell
us the path where
you want to output the file.
You have to give us
in advance the width
and the height of the image.
And the source of the image
can come from a bitmap.
But it can also
come from a surface.
So you don't necessarily
have, for instance,
if you're doing GR rendering, or
if you're doing video playback,
you can include that
directly as an image.
You don't have to go through
an intermediate bitmap.
And then when you
call writer to choose,
you can add multiple bitmaps.
In this case, we're
adding only one.
And when you call
stop, we write it out.
CHET HAASE: I
should point out too
that even though it's spelled
HEIC, it's pronounced GIF.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
DAN SANDLER: Go.
ROMAIN GUY: What are
you still doing here?
Vulkan.
So this is the slide
that I'm excited about.
Very few of you will be.
And I'm sure you will be super
excited by things like subgroup
ops and YCrCb formats.
More seriously,
anybody who's building
middleware, for instance, the
Unity engine, the Orion engine,
or if you're building
games, Vulkan
is a low level graphics
API that gives you
a lot more control over the GPU
so you get higher performance
code.
And Vulkan 1.1 adds
new capabilities that
were not possible in OpenGL.
But it also closes
the gap with OpenGL.
So, for instance, the
support of protected content.
We were not able to play back
protected content in Vulkan
before.
So that will unlock a lot of
things, like video players,
for instance.
Neural networks APIs.
They are not technically part of
P. I mean, they are part of P,
but we announced
them in API level 27.
You might have missed that.
It's a C API that's designed
for machine learning.
It's also a fairly
low level API.
It's meant for basically
playback of trained models.
So things like TensorFlow
are built on top
of your neural network API.
So you would use TensorFlow
to do all the learning.
And the neural network
APIs can do basically
the inference on device.
The interesting thing is that
we're also unlocking the access
to the DSP that
we use on Pixel 2
so you can get hardware
accelerated machine learning
effectively on select devices.
ARCore you just saw in
the developer keynote.
A couple months ago we
introduced ARCore 1.0.
And they just
announced ARCore 1.2.
This takes care of tracking
things in the real world.
The problem is that you had
to write a lot of OpenGL code.
And it's not always pleasant.
So to makes your
life easier, we're
introducing support
in the emulator.
So when you create an AVD, you
can specify a virtual camera
stream for the back camera,
and you get the full 3D scene.
And it works in any view that
displays the camera stream.
And using the keyboard
and the mouse,
you can just navigate
around the UI.
You even get patterns
on that fake TV screen
so you can do image
recognition and pattern
tracking, that kind of stuff.
It's available today.
Also we have Sceneform.
So they already talked
about it in the dev keynote.
I won't talk about it too much.
I will only say, this is
what I've been working on
for the past few months.
So I still don't have a
name, because we did that
to Daydream.
But anyway, that's
what I was up to.
And if you want to know
more about Sceneform,
there is a talk tomorrow
afternoon at 5:30 PM.
And we're going to talk
about the underlying tech
and how to use the API.
And finally, Chrome
OS on Pixelbook,
you can now run
Linux applications
on your Chromebook.
And in particular, you
can run Android Studio.
I believe there are
some limitations.
But one of the things you can
do is run your Android apps
as apps on Chrome OS.
So you can use Chrome OS as a
full blown Android development
platform, I guess
whenever it's available.
[CLAPPING]
Many, many more sessions
today, tomorrow, and Thursday.
You know, I said
earlier, there's
a lot of folks
back home who have
been doing all the hard work.
We're just talking about it.
So thank you very much
to all the engineering
teams, and the PMs, and the
designers, and tech writers,
everyone who made this possible.
We didn't do anything.
We're just here to
hear you be happy.
CHET HAASE: Some of
us did even less.
ROMAIN GUY: Yes.
And that's it for today.
So thank you very much.
DAN SANDLER: See you at
the Sandbox office hours.
Bring your questions.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
We have Framework office hours.
There is Android Sandbox
running all week.
DAN SANDLER: We've
done our best to bring
as many people
from our teams here
to be able to talk to you
about these new features,
these new APIs as
possible, because we
know you can't get that anywhere
else besides Google I/O.
CHET HAASE: And also
there's an overflow area.
I can't remember
where it is exactly.
Most of the speakers
from Android sessions
will make their way afterwards.
So if you can't get
your question answered
at the session, you should
be able to find them
after that, like us there now.
Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]